So it goes on in the Waske from
Serbia, yes I've had that
several times before, yes the former bishop G4
is a very good variant for Black
as E6, yes black is
always solid in the
positions here,
so Black somehow hasn't drawn C6 here,
that's
unusual  But I don't think you can
take advantage of it directly. I'll take the
d5 game of knight
C3. White's idea is now
to play here in the medium term with E4, so E2
E4 and then play after de here with vi against 3
on the kingside.
Another option would be here
specifically also knight
H4 D5 again Angren D knight F5
but first I'll make a
preparatory move here so now he makes
C6 well then I'll play
E4
H6
aha looks strange in my opinion
the
move principle nothing has threatened yet
somehow so if I now  Knight Knight
H4 F5 is an
idea but I could also just
develop myself further with bishop
E3 ​​or maybe bishop
F4. Play with bishop F4, it actually belongs
to E3 but I now wanted bishop
E3 ​​bishop C5 wasn't entirely
clear to me. Knight C5 is
surprisingly good  First of all, if we do
D1, I would expect Queen B6,
so unfortunately now we ca
n't move Knight D4 because
the pin still
exists, but you can first do G4
and then jump Knight E5 or Knight
D4, and of
course the queen on B6 is always potentially in
Bishop E3 ​​in so bishop E3 ​​and then
the diagonal E3 to
A7
yes I'll
cover the
knight E4 is often attacked by Black
but I've covered it often enough
and now I'm actually
ready for F4 F5 Queen A6 yes I might want to
go to C4 which is true  somehow it does
n't work that much Br bring B5 B4 that
could be an idea but
okay F4 is H anyway
according to plan and I think he has to
do something about F5 and
E5 looks somehow
dangerous,
you always just have to  Be
careful that when you move everything forward you do
n't end up with endless holes yourself.
It's good for white,
but somehow there are still
chances to counter, that's nice
Tower D4 maybe one possibility is
Tower D4 Bishop C5 I could now also
move knight F5 would be possible
or I could
also do knight B3 and
say that I am now threatening F5 and
knight E6 was actually a stupid move. Let's
see,
for example, if you have an
endgame  arises where I got to F5 and then
bishop H7,
that should actually be very pleasant.
I'll do it now
F5, let's see where it goes,
maybe it could even go to G5 because on H4
then knight would go G4, although that
's questionable but somehow on G5
He has a perspective so he definitely wants to go
to E5 somehow but here it should
actually be good if I reduce a
bit
of material as I said. An
endgame would be fine with me here because the
run on H7 is really night watchman so
he needs a few more moves first
now he has captured with the bishop,
it is of course
possible, but I could now
make knight C5 and use the
queen B6 field. I could also make queen F2, for example,
and then the deductions threaten, that
actually looks harmonious. I don't even know
if there is really any deduction
concretely threatening
but definitely makes a
harmonious
impression here
so
m here now maybe just runner
F4 but well it doesn't do that much good no not
nim first the
D line
aha I'm not on the bill as if
he wants to he wants to
block E5 time
warning  I'd better go
back and play now Bishop F4
so so he's managed the blockade here for now,
but
um he has to stop with all the pieces
on it
so red
G5
so has now caught up significantly in terms of time
so G5 on knight D3 I
still have the intermediate move
GF6  so so so so
if I don't make a
big mistake here, this one
piece wins because it's hanging down here,
so rook E5 rook D8 or queen E5 D5
rook B5 rook D8 is even mated, because
the bishop is such a sad piece.
Check like this  We won the piece like
that and
now
check sh
give it
out so I think he has to take it too
time exceeded yes that
looked like a pretty bad win
the whole structure is
certainly a bit uncomfortable for
Black simply because of the always very
problematic bishop  On G6, which is then
so difficult to stand on H, the
enormous space disadvantage is of course also
a
problem, since you somehow ca
n't cope with the position and
luckily it
took up a bit of time so that I didn't
get into any serious problems
am